in terms of NYU um why did you choose
NYU and what did it teach you um I think
I tried to stay away from film school
for as long as possible thinking I could
make films on my own and you know it's
really expensive to go there and but
eventually I kind of like was like oh I
just really really want to do this and I
kind of gave in and I think it's been
amazing just in terms of the people I've
met um like I just can't imagine going
back and not having those people to work
with and like you know whether it's
james or the producer on this film or
people who are going to work on it like
a lot of them are just like close
friends that I've collaborated with NYU
um and just some great professors and
but really the community is pretty
special and then like being able to keep
working with these people um after you
graduate